the x-men are coming into the MCU
something that we have wanted to here
for such a long time now and yesterday
we got one step closer to that happening
with Marvel dropping a huge bomb on us
and most likely given us the way that
the x-men will enter the MCU I'll talk
about Marvel's plan to introduce the
x-men into the MCU in this video but
first I want to announce my new giveaway
I'm giving away Marvel Legends series
items such as Captain America shield
iron man's helmet Black Panthers helmet
star Lords helmet and of course the
Infinity Gauntlet at the 400,000
subscriber mark I will pick not one but
three winners and the winner will choose
one item that they want from the Marvel
legend series I'll talk about this more
at the end of the video but be sure to
subscribe so you can enter so yesterday
we got the second spider-man far from
home trailer and Marvel dropped a huge
bombshell on us introducing multiverses
into the MCU people have actually been
theorizing for a very long time now that
multiverses are going to be the way that
the x-men and the Fantastic Four enter
the MCU and with yesterday's
introduction to the multiverse it seems
like we were pretty dead-on with that so
the x-men can enter the MCU through the
multiverse and they're already setting
that up and spider-man far from home
with bringing Mysterio in from another
universe we're gonna use someone like
you on my world new world Vic is from
Earth just not house a snap to our home
in our dimension so this is it they've
already brought one character in from
another universe another earth and
that's how they're going to bring the X
minute and the CEO of Disney Bob Iger
has already confirmed that the x-men
will be in the MCU
he's already publicly stated that there
should only be one Marvel Cinematic
Universe and that the x-men and the
Fantastic Four should be in the same
universe as the Avengers he said it just
makes sense and now that Marvel has
introduced multiverses into the MCU it's
so much easier to bring them in one of
the biggest problems and questions that
everybody had about bringing the x-men
into the MCU was where were the x-men
and the Fantastic Four during all these
events of the Avengers how could they
fly under the radar for so long with
people like Nick Fury looking for super
people well with the idea of multiverses
it makes perfect sense the x-men and the
tastic for have been out there fighting
villains just not in the same reality in
universe that the Avengers exist in but
now there's a way to bring them into the
main universe that we've all seen in the
MCU and this will most likely happen due
to some major threat that's going to
come in the future there's most likely
going to be some huge villain that the
heroes in our current universe have no
idea how to handle such as Galactus or
some cosmic entities and it's already
been confirmed that Marvel wanted to
bring the cosmic entities during the
events of Avengers infinity war but
ultimately decided not to the
screenwriters have already confirmed
that they were going to introduce The
Living Tribunal and Avengers infinity
war and Marvel is going into the cosmic
future we know that so The Avengers are
most likely going to run into some
threats that they don't really know how
to deal with and since in spider-man far
from home Mysterio is grabbed from
another earth they'll most likely do
that to go get mutants and the Fantastic
Four and again
this is already being set up Marvel has
taken the first step by introducing the
multiverse in spider-man far from home
and grabbing Mysterio from that
different universe this is something
that has been planned for a very long
time and now the Disney Fox deal is
officially done and Marvel can use the
x-men and Fantastic Four in the MCU so
it probably won't be immediate but the
x-men will be entering the MCU and
Marvel has already taken that first step
so let me know how excited you all are
for the x-men to enter the MCU and now
we're gonna get into the giveaway stuff
as I mentioned before when I hit 400,000
subscribers I'm going to be picking not
one but three giveaway winners each
winner will choose one item that they
want from the Marvel Legends series
there will be multiple ways to enter
this giveaway but of course you must be
subscribed to my channel to enter and
there will be other ways as well that I
will introduce a little bit later and of
course be sure to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to Marvel including the x-men and the
Fantastic Four entering the MCU as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]